los llamamientos para que alexander
lukashenko celebren nuevos comicios
justos son cada vez más fuertes por
parte del pueblo de belarús pero también
internacionalmente es una situación
terrible belarús la seguimos muy de
cerca liderando las llamadas están los
vecinos bálticos de belarús y polonia
lituania ha acusado a lukashenko de
aumentar las tensiones después de que
belarús comenzará a realizar ejercicios
militares en su frontera occidental yo
también es cauteloso de la respuesta de
rusia a los disturbios en su frontera
hasta la reacción de moscú ha sido
inusualmente contenida pero lukashenko
dice que ha prometido su ayuda a belarús
en caso de una amenaza militar externa
y no hay ninguna razón legal o de otro
tipo para que rusia proporcione apoyo
militar pero podría utilizarse como
tapadera para la invasión destruyendo
así los últimos restos de la
independencia de belarús por otra parte
considerando el apoyo público rusia
arriesgaría mucho si decidiera hacerlo
experts suelen escoger a cualquier
programa en su opinión el movimiento de
oposición de belarús no es anti rusia o
pro europa pero moscú se arriesga a
hacerlo enviando tropas por su parte la
unión europea ha acordado sanciones
contra los vuelos rusos que han violado
los derechos humanos naturales por
supuesto que también vemos la opción de
extender las sanciones a otras personas
responsables
outside twitteando la violencia contra
los manifestantes es inaceptable el
presidente del consejo europeo charles
michel dijo que los líderes de la unión
europea discutirán la represión en una
cumbre de emergencia el miércoles